encore une fois l'horreur et la
dévastation frappe les rues de la
capitale ukrainienne
la russie accentue ses frappes
militaires et bombarde kiev une attaque
aussitôt dénoncée vous sommet du g c'est
un
geste brutal de la barbarie distille qui
démontre qu'il ne faut pas céder un
pouce à vladimir poutine
plus tôt dans la journée les dirigeants
du g7 se sont moqués de vladimir poutine
devrions-nous garder mon veston demande
boris johnson
allons-y torse nu et à cheval renchérit
justin trudeau en référence à une photo
célèbre de vladimir poutine
la rencontre au sommet dans les
montagnes bavaroises devait servir à
démontrer l'harmonie des dirigeants du g
7 face à la russie pourtant la france et
l'amérique sont en désaccord sur la
façon de poursuivre la guerre justin
trudeau souhaite repousser complètement
la russie en dehors de l'ukraine alors
qu emmanuel macron semble plus ouvert à
un compromis
n'empêche le g7 prépare une nouvelle
série de sanctions
le canada et la grande-bretagne veulent
couper le flot de l'or vers la russie
pour punir les oligarques et freiner le
financement de la guerre en ukraine
justin trudeau n'exclut pas des
sanctions purement canadienne par
exemple dans le secteur des technologies
de l'innovation
autres dossiers urgents la crise
alimentaire la saison des récoltes
approche en ukraine la russie a détruit
des terminaux à grains qu'il faut
rebâtir le canada propose de partager
son expertise agricole c'est important
d'y arriver pour favoriser le
développement durable une main tendue
aux pays qui souffre de la crise
alimentaire causée par la guerre un
dossier crucial pour plusieurs pays
comme l'inde et l'afrique du sud
invité au sommet du g7 devant tous ces
enjeux en apparence contradictoires
les dirigeants marche sur un fil de fer
tout le monde ici s'entend pour dire
qu'on doit travailler ensemble pour
réduire les écarts en matière
d'investissements dans les
infrastructures dans les pays en
développement
c'est le dilemme des pays du g7 comment
punir vladimir poutine avait des
sanctions qui lui font mal sans pour
autant nuire au pays alliés ou à ceux du
sud ici que c'était à noël radio-canada
à garmisch partenkirchen en allemagne